having a hard time reaching your weight
loss goals dr nash can help
we spoke earlier today and looked at our
clients life-changing results
dr nash it is always great to have you
on the show and today it's extra special
for us because
one you brush your results the before
and after videos which i think are just
amazing secondly these are all new
patients of yours that we're gonna see
today
yes these are people that we haven't
talked about with your audience we're
always trying to help people see that if
you find what's going on underneath
anybody at any age with any kinds of
problems can get these issues fixed and
get them fixed for good
all right the first person we're going
to talk about let's watch april's video
when i first heard about dr nash i
thought that this was too good to be
true
then i started working the program and
my pants started falling off
this was the best investment i could
have made in myself tell me more about
april she has a special glow about
herself and i love her line when her
pants
were falling off from your program you
literally went to costco and you know
sometimes you have to reach up high for
something she reached she went one way
and her pants went the other way
and that was when she knew she probably
needed to start getting new clothes but
yeah
60 pounds total it's the skin and the
glow like everything she just radiates
health now
going on to norma check out norma's
video before dr nash
i was a junk food junkie in war size 14
but now i'm a size 6 8 and no longer
addicted to junk food
i love norman she she looks younger
after your program she has new energy
about herself
and you changed her lifestyle she no
longer eats junk food yeah you know this
one's a really big one with the current
situation that we're all struggling with
right now
maybe we're trying to make our money
stretch maybe we're just stressed out
and we're
heading and running towards the wrong
foods and that can be kind of hard when
you're alone
trying to figure it out so what she
didn't know is that it was hormones that
was driving that junk food behavior so
when we corrected the hormones
that behavior of cravings just naturally
fell away
the last one we'll look at here we have
veto take a look at veto
on dr nash's program i lost 170 pounds
and this is the result
seventy 170lbs vito he he lost me
is what he lost this is crazy tell me
more about this
no veto lost to jc fernandez like he did
he literally did so veto's a bittersweet
story a lot of times people ask me you
know do you only work with women
you know we usually see women on your
program i do work with men veto as an
example
his wife was dying of cancer and he made
a he made a promise to her that he would
lose the weight he's got 170 pounds down
he's kept it off for
years now all right every week you have
a special i'm sure this week is no
different what do you have for us
that's right of course you know that i'd
say that when i normally do the
evaluation it's 97
just for me to figure out what the heck
is wrong inside that body that's making
it so stubborn
but if you mention that you saw me on
las vegas now with jc then i'm going to
give you a spot in
for that evaluation at 9.97 i
actually only have 10 spots i only have
them for this week if you try to look it
up for next week there's not going to be
anything available
this week the best way to get it would
be to go to the website that we keep
showing you on the screen i'd love to
talk to you and see if we can help you
get results like these guys